good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to this evening's meeting of
planning West I'm the chairman just
encouraged this meeting is open to the
public but only those members of the
public who have registered to speak and
the ward member can actually speak to
the committee I'd ask everyone to
respect that the other members of the
planning committee are sitting in front
of me we'll go through the agenda for
each for each planning application our
planning officer will introduce it those
members of the public registered will
speak the committee members will ask
some questions if they need to and then
the officer questions if they need to
and then debate it and come to a
decision
our ask the officers on either side of
me to introduce themselves before we
begin starting committee administrator
Welsh chambers from legal services
manager my role I'm an impartial advisor
to the committee I can clarify any
planning issues that arise doing so I'm
bound by the code of Professional
Conduct of the Royal Town Planning
Institute bound by the Shawn Gardner
assistant planner thank you
if we go through are there any apologies
for absence lovely does anyone have an
disclosure of interest Thank You
councillor Richards
and Cher um the first application which
I believe is now being withdrawn was in
my pouch I wasn't to speak but I don't
think we need to worry too much about
that one now the second one 1800 746 ful
also in my patch I have made
representation in the past on this site
for very similar I
I will be withdrawing myself from the
committee although I won't be speaking
later on
thank you very much right so minutes of
okay so you've had an email about the
application for the nursery yeah I've
had an email for an up put the
application actually which has been
dropped for hoaxford farm so that
doesn't matter
cows arkinson yes in a minute in a
minute if we go through the minutes and
we only have the minutes I think for the
the annual meeting and then the actual
last meeting will come next time
everyone happy with the minutes yep good
thanks
so yes number four item number four on
the agenda application 1703 Oh two nine
Hawksworth farm Gospel Hoagland has been
withdrawn so we won't be doing that I
would like to bring forward item 7
Paradise Lodge tinker's farm cottage as
the next item if that's okay and I would
like to propose that we defer thank you
defer this item because of exceptional
personal circumstances meaning that the
applicant the applicants agent isn't
able to speak tonight so could we vote
on deferring all those of favor of
deferring oh I need a seconder sorry
I'll take Molly as a seconder and then
all in favor of deferring or against and
any abstentions thank you so everyone
great
does you want a few minutes to read the
update sheet because it's quite a lot on
the next item just very few minutes
okay everyone okay lovely so if we can
go to item 5 which is application 18
double O seven four six four part of
England farms Hanley Road and Victoria
shed away things Thank You chairman hmm
banning consent assault for the
demolition over building use for the
rearing of game birds and then for its
replacement with a building of a purpose
design for the purposes of hatchery
included incubation units and associated
storage the site forms part at the heart
of England farm the site is located is
indicated by the black dot on this slide
here's the red line boundary for the
site which includes access to the site
from the adopted highway at Henley Road
the site is located in open countryside
within an area of special sorry within a
special landscape area and within the
Greenbelt this slide shows the layout of
the existing buildings on site the red
box on the slide indicates the building
to be demolished and as such also the
site for the proposed replacement
building for the hatchery building the
overall holding is used in a mix
agricultural and gamebird rearing and
breeding enterprise these are obviously
the elevations for the proposed
replacement hatchery building the
proposed building would measure
approximately 21 metres in width
eighteen point five metres in depth and
seven point six meters to ridge height
the building would be finished with
plastic coated box profiles steel
cladding to be coloured brown the
proposed building would contain a
mezzanine accessed externally as shown
on the elevations the building would be
insulated to provide a refrigerated
environment the incubators would occupy
approximately 40% of the ground-floor
area and the remainder of the building
would be used in connection with the
hatchery operation which includes
counting sorting and transferring of
transference of the game birds
the applicant has stated that the
building is thought to improve working
conditions for the employees and animal
welfare on site this slide shows a
comparison between the height of the
existing building to be demolished and
the replacement building in the context
of the existing surrounding buildings
the building be in the gray building in
the middle the proposed replacement
building would be 2.7 meters higher to
ridge height these images views of the
existing building as used from the south
the photo at the top here is a view of
the site from the west and the bottom
image is viewed from the east the arrow
shows the location of an approved rural
workers dwelling on site adjacent to the
proposed new building or where the new
building would be these are further
views of the existing building in
context as viewed from the southwest at
the top sorry the southwest in both
locations you can see in the background
there some conifer trees these are along
the boundary to the north of the site
and these are wider context images these
are from the north and west these are
further away again from the Northwest
these are to the southeast chairman
there are updates which were in the
update sheet and the officer
recommendation is to grant planning
permission thank you thank you now we
have here that councillor Lawton
chairman of Clevedon Parish Council will
be speaking is anyone here from
Clevedon parish council known at all
okay then we'll go to Keith Williams the
agent for the applicant with old
groaning I believe
and I have you down here as joint
speakers
we'll get you another one
in actual fact mr. browning will be
speaking I'm here solely to answer any
planning questions before I start
however could I just make a correction
on the photographs that have been
displayed to you one of the photographs
indicated the site of the new rural
workers dwellings that is in fact
incorrect that is where there was an old
apartment that was replaced okay thank
you just what to be make it clear that
members was very useful so thank you so
mr. groaning you'll have three minutes
we'll give you a two and a half minute
warning start when you're ready thank
you good evening I just wanted to make a
few notes and obviously answer any
questions that the committee may have
some of those have been duplicated by
the additional justification so I will
try and split those outs which have
already been those points which have
already been covered in the additional
justification house sheets which which
the business is one of four large game
businesses in the UK we seem to each
cover different geographical areas me
being in the center having a central
location means that we can deliver
deliver day-old chicks which have a
limited shelf life if you like have a
limited lifetime from when they're
hatched being central we can reach a
much larger location and therefore
demand always seems to outstrip supply
for the day-old chicks the markets
traditionally has been filled by French
producers which have been very
successful but the difficulties with
live imports have now been highlighted
with both animal health scares and also
implications which seems to be very much
people's front of people's minds so the
French producers are now stepping back
maybe from supplying chicks to this
country looking to supply older birds
live in the chick market very wide open
to the existing producers who are able
to produce it the project will benefit
jobs it will improve the through the
service to customers and ayran us to get
the chicks processed in a quicker period
of time and delivered in a quicker
period of time and hopefully also
improve czech health and definitely
welfare the building will mainly allow
space for larger and more modern and
reliable machines the machines are used
one of them is a a chick counter which
the faster the chicks can be counted and
into their boxes then the quicker they
can be on the road to their destination
so a larger and more modern chick
counter would benefit benefit the
business greatly and also the welfare of
the chicks
it would also we also need to improve
from the machine which we're using now
which we're finding is not as accurate
as we would like it to be and we are
having the few complaints of chicks with
numbers in the boxes be erratic the new
hatchery equipment will improve
innovation in particular in the area of
waste removal of shells and the cleaning
of hatching drugs which is so important
for the tip security 30 seconds it will
also continue the year-round activity
and use of the buildings which is so
important to the business to enable the
staff to be occupied throughout the year
the building would have a secondary use
as a cold store for the turkey side of
the business and the Christmas months
when it wasn't being used in the winter
months when it wasn't being used as a
hatchery that's it I'm afraid
thank you questions I'll be pleased to
answer perfect councillor Giles
obviously one of the things that's
listed is improving welfare and handling
of chicks and one example you've given
is the chick counting and the ways in
which that should improve welfare are
there any other examples as to how this
particular building will assist with the
welfare aspect that's still in use now
none of the buildings are better drains
with better ceilings with all of the
buildings but we've never really had a
purpose-built building we operate a
one-way system for disease proportions
so eggs go in one end and chicks go out
of the other end but we like to continue
that throughout afternoon with a new
building with impervious materials this
will be used for the actual hatching as
opposed to the incubation so they only
move into this room three days before
they hatch and there's specialist
machines which actually hatch them and
those we then pass that as the dirty
room if you like in that it needs to be
cleaned on a weekly basis as opposed to
the incubators where there's no bacteria
release if you like so those are cleaned
anywhere near as much so the capital
buildings are okay for the incubators
but this will definitely improve one
more from castor Jones
so is this building looking for you to
increase the volume of chicks that you
produce essentially
but that's not its main plan is to put
more modern machines in which are larger
and it could give the scope to do it but
it's not that it's not its primary
purpose at the moment now to improve
what's going through the hatchery we
would have to increase the amount of
breeding birds which we have and we
haven't it's more we are almost
strangled by the buildings which we have
at the moment this would just allow the
working protocols to hopefully work so
much better smooth I feel that it will
be a benefit but it would long it would
also allow a greater expansion but that
is my marry purpose only Thank You
councillor Barnes the hatching season
because pheasants are seasonal bird they
only lay for 12 weeks of the year so the
hatchery is only actually an operation
for 12 weeks of the year we need large
numbers of staff through the through the
busy time so not only do we breed the
birds we rear the birds and then when
that extends the season to 36 weeks and
then we fill in the if you like the
slack time in the middle by producing
numbers of turkeys for the Christmas
market so the turkey business is quite
considerable on its own now your
original was your original business so
this building being an insulated
building made with modern materials and
impervious materials we will be fitting
refrigerators to it so that we can use
it as a as a store for for turkeys after
they've been processed
what about ventilation then there will
be a specialist ventilation system for
each incubator and also just extraction
units above the chick counting tables
but they would just be blocked off or
filled in for the Christmas time when
when it would be used as a large fridge
we haven't got a fridge at the moment
where we can access with a forklift so
all the turkeys have to be manually
carried in and out
so just having a building with a with a
forklift access would save a lot of
drudgery lovely no more I've got a few
so you mentioned sort of refrigerators
and fans and things any comments on the
noise these might make and how that
might affect there's a mezzanine floor
which is only part used for packaging
and then the fridge units would sit on
top of that okay and in the up that's
what the upstairs is for okay and just
for clarification the workers dwelling
is further to the east is it then shown
lovely any other questions thank you
very much and council issues isn't
speaking on this so are there any
technical questions for the offices I
just got one we're okay with that we
signing of the the workers dwelling so I
seem to remember that's correct okay so
open for debate
cancer bonds to the birds after then
there's no profit so we have a proposal
there Thank You councillor for drew does
anyone want to say anything can cancel
jobs
I'm definitely an agreement with the
aspect of the offices report which says
it's inappropriate development in the
Greenbelt so I think that there needs to
be justification on the basis of very
special circumstances I do consider one
circumstance that potentially goes that
is the issue of animal welfare and some
of the processes being streamlined
although that's counterbalance to is
with if processes become more intense if
it increases the risk that animal
welfare is detrimental II affected so I
have to say I'm sort of balanced because
the problem with the other very special
circumstances business use rural
business is that could be used on in
that justification could be used on lots
of sites in the green boat and could
always justify an expansion in the green
boat so I think the committee needs to
be satisfied that all of those things
cumulatively really do amount to very
special circumstances okay
nothing then I think we'll go to the
vote on that straight away we've had a
proposer to grant this application all
those in favor of granting please raise
your hands and against and abstain
lovely then this committee has resolved
to growth planning application 1800
seven four six stroke full
so the next one is kiloton Road you're
going to speak on this onion and David
if you can introduce Antony sorry
thank you sure the application is in the
centre of Ulster it's relating to polka
dot Day Nursery and it's for variation
to a previous permission so it's to vary
the condition of the previous permission
relating to the approved plans and the
reason for the application is that an
affair you can appear was erected which
didn't accord with the details of those
of that previous approval and this is an
application retrospective application
because the new canopy is in place so
this is an applicant retrospective
application to to have that a proposal
considered and hopefully approved so
here we have the the site center of
Ulster next to the river and site edged
red here but the Purple Line is the edge
of the conservation area in the red
rectangle there is the listed bridge and
the canopy as you'll see is of the rear
aerial shot so there's there's the
nursery building on this area here is
the covered area for the canopy so
neighboring properties arrow Bank and on
the right and the left are property
called overstream again the bridge and
the river running around here here's the
canopy itself with an arched top open
sided perspex roof to provide shelter
for the children when they're outdoors
and just so members can understand
potentially meaning its community
impacts they offer sustains from a
photograph from the neighboring
neighboring garden and you can just see
the top of the canopy roof there
projecting above the the hedgerow and a
more distant shot here on the bottom
photograph members are joining course of
consideration of the application and and
in some way to try and mitigate mitigate
some of the impacts that were expressed
by the neighbor the applicant has agreed
to in addition add a screen screen
perspex screen onto the side of the the
canopy in the hope that that would
potentially reduce any any any excessive
noise but that noise hasn't really been
raised as an issue by environmental
health but this in some way I guess
would mitigate amenity to some extent
just showing you the elevations and to
give members an idea what was previously
here we have the red outline of the
approved canopy side elevation as you
can see the new canopy extends further
out from the building and rear elevation
the approved canopy was slightly wider
than what what is proposed at the moment
and again a roof plan
members the application is to as the
recommendation is to approve with the
addition of the additional condition on
the update sheet relating to the screen
to the side of the canopy Thank You
chair Thank You Anthony right so we have
some speakers from the time
Ulster Town Council councillor Clive
Neil Sturgis who knows very well I'm
sure the protocol three minutes with a
half a minute warning it's not okay yep
thank you planning committee respective
planning application we submitted a
holding objection pending a site visit
which the some ability to actually took
place on the 23rd of April contrary to
the officers views we the Town Council
Planning Committee considered it does do
significant harm but a following reasons
it is a very significant departure from
the original proposal both in size and
and now it can be seen from all parts of
we considered it is somewhat obtrusive
industrial design situated close to or
partly in the conservation area and so
we consider bit detrimental
the Planning Committee
thank you any questions okay well I'll
just have one you're happy with the if
it was to go ahead you're happy with the
the extra condition for the noise that's
on the right side is it yes yes it in as
far as it goes because if you are minded
to prove this application then we would
appreciate okay I just want to make sure
we got it on the right side
thank you any other questions okay
second
so when you mention that it's
applications because there isn't any
mention of that in our report possibly
remiss maybe it's a more general point
we've had this is one of three
significant which again I that's not to
do with this application Center yeah
okay any other questions no thank you
very much
and now we have Mike Trevor the
applicant hello who again probably knows
yes please do that's probably safer
tonight yes you're quite welcome to so
you have three minutes I have made some
notes please do yeah please you've got
three minutes and I'll give you a half
minute warning when you get to two and a
half okay thank you
polka dot Ulster was opened in August
2014 we currently have about 120 local
austere parents who used the nursery the
children range in age from nine months
to five years and we also employ sixteen
members of staff the original planning
consent as you've already heard from
2014 did include permission to cover the
outdoor space with an open side of the
canopy and we were therefore surprised
to be a form that the canopy we've put
up doesn't meet the agreed plan
hence this application the canopy is for
the sole benefit of the children who
attend the nursery I need to enable them
to maximize the time that they can spend
outside and outdoors the garden is
south-facing and the children access the
outdoor space every day come rain or
shine throughout the day and throughout
the year these very young children need
some protection from from the UV
obviously in when it does the Sun does
shine and protection from rain snow or
the winter because this we've created an
outdoor learning space that inspires and
interests all children polka-dot believe
that the benefits about they'll play
have a positive impact on the children's
lives as do others namely a recent
survey concluded that up to
three-quarters of UK children spend less
time outside than prison inmates 75% of
children spend less than 60 minutes
a day playing outside young children
that can learn and play outside to get
direct experience of the weather the
seasons and the wildlife they get to
assess risk they get to solve problems
and they developed creativity
Environment Secretary Liz Rush noted
that only 10% of children currently have
access to out to an outdoor learning
space the RSPB
published a 3-year study concluding that
four out of five children in the UK were
not adequately connected to nature and
less than ten percent regularly played
in wild spaces compared to half the
children a generation ago the NHS
guidelines said that children under five
should get three hours exercise per day
and it should be a mixture of bone
strengthening muscle building and
cardiovascular a polka dot we ensure
that all these activities oh sorry
through activities such as running
cycling digging and climbing these needs
are met every day mr. Reedy is objected
to the canopy sighting in 30 seconds
noise levels however we point out that
mr. Reedy lives next door to st.
benedict's high school which has eight
hundred secondary school pupils
generating a significant amount north of
the day but when the children attend
nursery mr. Reedy is out at work when
mr. Reedy is most likely to be using
this garden I the evening and weekends
the nursery shut the canopies are not
true so if he can't be seen from the
road and it's only partly visible from
mr. really is rear garden I'm afraid I'm
afraid that said I'm gonna have to stop
you there at three minutes thank you
very much
we do have some questions councillor
Giles sorry I didn't quite understand
I remember approving this application I
just didn't quite understand the
explanation for why the canopy has built
now didn't conform to the original plan
that was approved because we mistake we
we thought we thought we were we were in
compliance but obviously we weren't
right okay
the question has gone from my mind
should we come back to you
yes counselor bones that was I think
that was a different application we
wanted to change the pitched roof you
know we you had one email I think from
mr. Reedy
we can give you a hundred emails from
hundred very happy parents that's right
thank you you want us to provide that
we're happy to councillor Giles hasn't
come back okay
thank you very much and now it's a
council of pain not five or six five
minutes if you want them
chairman members of the West area
planning committee firstly I would like
to say that my adjacent warm-water
member and I are concerned about the
number of retrospective planning
applications we have had in our town
recently and here we are we have another
one this evening the Town Council are
also concerns about this matter as
you've already heard and have raised the
matter with mr. weeks the property now
known as polka dot day nursery was
originally built as a manga low for
residential living after a number of
years it was converted into a Medical
Center following the construction of a
new also health center the building
became vacant and was then taken over by
polka dot day nursery the nursery is set
between two residential properties these
being overstream and Ira bank with the
conservation boundary line running
through all three gardens at the rear
during its time as a bungalow there was
very little change to the property
however when the building was converted
into a house center and number of
extensions and alterations were done
this has continued since it became polka
dot day nursery and what case of ours
was talking about was the last
application that counted due to this
committee the property known as era Bank
is an older property and was there long
before the construction of a bungalow
this variation will have an overbearing
impact on this property as it is very
close to the boundary fence between the
two properties especially when added to
the alterations and extensions which
have recently been granted the variation
before utilized is for a huge blue
canopy which has a depth of six point
eight meters a width of 10 meters and
eve's heights of 3.2 meters and the
height of four point two meters to the
tallest point this will have an
overbearing impact on the neighboring
poverty no no arrow bank and no interest
obtrusive design and color be
inappropriate so close to the
conservation area the reason we wouldn't
hold on the side visit I went on the
site visit to
to look at it the reason we're told that
the stroke was not right and the
rainwater wouldn't run off and that's
whether it was heightened therefore I
ask you to refuse the variation of
condition to of planet Bishop permission
reference 14 double zero three four four
very to allow retrospective alterations
to the approve cannot be designed
however if the committee is minded to
approve the application I ask that would
probably change from blue to green as
this would be more sympathetic to the
area thank you that's finished chairman
thanks sorry thank you any questions
Kaster Barnes the neighbor also all over
this object okay thank you any other
questions
no Thank You councillor thank you Jim
okay we've got some technical questions
first of all we'll just clear up this
blue to green business which I doubt we
can do retrospectively but I'll ask it
could be done retrospectively if members
consider that blues and accept it but
obviously off the officers consider is
acceptable as it stands and causes no
harm positive members were minded to go
down that route it could you could put a
condition on that within a certain
period to be painted a color to be
agreed yes just because it's
retrospective doesn't mean like a I
presume this is see-through if some kind
of assume it's true throw into the
framework all right okay thank you
right okay cool that's great any other
questions
Kalibak
or is it painting thank you yeah
cats arkinson but is the current color
arrangement coordinating with the rest
of the building which we're talking
about
as you can see from the photograph it's
a brick building with a tile roof and
the canopy is blue so no they're not the
same color and equally a green wouldn't
be the same color as the house any other
questions no open to debate then cancer
Giles I don't accept the explanation
that this was a mistake in terms of the
bill it's so completely different from
what was on the plan including a big
curved roof so unless you're incapable
of seeing the difference between a curve
and the line I think that sounds
implausible
however we are judging this on what
would be the case to come before us and
I do recall when I sat on this before
the principal objection actually wasn't
about what was going on at the back but
was what whether the substantive side
extensions would cause a light
difficulty in the room of the neighbor
so actually the canopy wasn't the big
issue at the back I do you think it's
ugly and I do think it is visible from a
neighboring property but I think it
would be a stretch to say that it is
obtrusive in terms of neighboring
amenity because it's not just about
whether enable lights looking at it it's
about does it intrude on their light so
on and so forth so I think that would be
difficult so I think I would have much
preferred the original design that was
approved by this committee however I
don't think it's so intrusive that
there's a planning reason to refuse it
however I do feel that the condition for
this side perspex in terms of noise
would be appropriate and I would also
think a condition to paint the framework
green would help it to be more in
keeping particularly from the neighbors
point of view and from a design point of
view in my opinion that would be more
appropriate so I would propose grant but
with the addition of that condition
about
repainting it into a color that's agreed
with them officer and that being a green
shade or variety or more in keeping
thank you
and yeah cancel when they built an extra
[ __ ] and basically from what I can
gather it with the only nursery school
and they got more children than they
expected and obviously there was a big
garden the river arrow is at the bottom
of this there which we were concerned
about floating it's a big area where
they got a play and they do need a cover
I would like a green really much like
the last speakers okay any other
speakers councillor Vaudrey how was the
debate I do you think the color point
just smacks of because it's
retrospective if we're going to punish
the person for the sake of it I just
whether it's blue or green it's still
gonna look like a big structure but I
accept Council of Payne's comment about
retrospective applications and they do
seem to be a flood of them these days we
are where we are and I have no objection
to the actual building that's there so I
will vote in favor I would prefer to
have I would like to if I'm able to I
like proposed motion it doesn't have the
kind of thing but if the color thing is
the dominant one then I know it's been
seconded have and I'll support that for
the basis you should get permission I
think pedantic points to a strange the
color okay thank you
you can always vote against it and and
proposed of in favor later because we'll
need a second vote anyway if it goes
down councillor Richard I'm not going to
go through all the points have been
raised already I'm generally
generally speaking an agreement with the
majority of them this whole color thing
I've got a particular issue with the
color but if we're gonna insist that a
colorist put color has changed first of
all you need to find out if it's
feasible I would imagine that a powder
coated frame will a new cope have a
powder coated or is he going to put over
the top if it's probably top is it just
gonna wear away after a while and it's
green gonna be appropriate for the
school there may be and rival school
next door that has green and it would
have been appropriate to do that so I
think rather than setting a specific
color a color to be agreed with the
applicant and the chair of the committee
if we have so I'm getting nods from Sir
Giles there so we can do something like
that we're gonna look at the
practicality of it so it's not going to
be an insistence well I mean if it's
because if it is a powder coat and and
it's just gonna flake off it's gonna
look far worse than it is at the moment
so unless you're asking them to take the
whole thing down and powder coat at a
different color which if you are that's
fine
I just want to condition which expresses
that there should be some further
consideration to the color and it should
be painted a more neutral and in keeping
color with the vegetation and
surrounding area so whether that's a
more neutral green or a brown or
something of that nature rather than a
big bright color bearing in mind yes
this is a school and a nursery but it
operates within the vicinity of a
residential area that's my reason for it
so you what if you insist yeah see I
just want to get clear if you're
insisting that this color is changed to
something more appropriate rather than
if it's possible to do that in a
reasonable manner you're insisting that
it happens well you know that's the
clarification I want yes I would like my
proposal is that condition changes but I
agree there ought to be the color ought
to be okay with officer in through chat
Thank You council bars you have enough
and the applicant has seen that we would
prefer green to blue when we've had a
proposal for an extra condition on on a
different color so we're going to go
with that okay so we haven't got a
second at the moment have you got a
second if cancer and a modest proposal
with that amendment Molly that'll do
it's a seconder for that once again we
don't think we can find a seconder for
council Giles can we nope okay so the
next proposal is the same thing with a
note and we have a seconder for that I
don't know what the notes
I just want if we could I just want
absolute clarity that if that what
councillor chance is proposing is that
they can there is a condition and I want
I want confirmation of the office as
well whether this is right or not that
there is a condition that the color of
the frame is changed and that color has
to be agreed by the applicant and
officers through our chair is that legal
it would meet the test I think it's
borderline reasonable given that it
probably as you say is powder coated it
would be difficult to do but it's not
impossible to do and therefore if
members feel strongly that blue is the
wrong color and that's the only way to
support it then they could add the
condition council our concern
something I mean in many conservation
areas you know we're capsule when
looking for a seconder at the moment but
I imagine if he went through Ulster
you'd find blue on many front doors and
on window ledges
I just think quite frankly it's a new
position which doesn't have any
credibility okay right thank you I'm
going to go now with the the suggestion
the proposal we have from councillor
bombs seconded by Councillor Vaudrey we
could vote it down if you wish to put a
note on mm-hmm
can you tell us what the note might
affect yep I just clarified and put a
note on obviously then it's optional
whether the applicant chooses to do it
but the note could say it's the view of
the planning authority that this ought
to be painted a green color something
something to that effect that's what it
would say keeping okay well we know
exactly what that means now if we're
happy with that
all in favor or against okay thank you
so this committee has resolved to grant
planning application 1800 six nine zero
very with the with the additional
conditions in the report and on the
update sheet and the note just discussed
thank you very much
right so we're going on to the next item
the Old Rectory whom will corner it's
item eight on the agenda and Shawn
Gardner will give us a description
thank you very much sure okay this this
site is located in a small village of
Kinison sorry this this site is the pit
in the small village of Kineton which
lies to the east of Ulster
kinnison is a very small settlement it
comprises of occasional dwellings farm
buildings that glebe farm the old
directory itself and the Church of st.
Mary the Virgin the river all meow me
Anders to the southeast of the site as
members can see this is rural location
also washed over by the Greenbelt and
has been designated as ODS and special
landscape area there are trees along the
North the northern and southern
boundaries of the application site and
on the river a public footpath it's just
a noted in red there if you can see that
runs north and northeast past the
difficut you probably just see the
difficut there and blue ok so this is
the site plan so the site of the
proposed outbuilding is marked there
with the arrow just to the northeast
just next to the st. Mary's Church
moving on to the proposals the existing
and proposed site plan planning
permission is actually sought for the
construction of an outbuilding
on a disused tennis court to the
northeast of the site it would comprise
of his swimming pool greenhouse walled
garden area boiler house gym and games
room so a gym and games area and a
change in area in association with the
to import these the elevations and the
side elevations
and the floorplan closer at floor pan
flan there the building would be about
450 square meters and around 1,800 cubic
meters around 5 meters to the ridge of
the lantern proposed so this is the rear
of the property and here is our
application site or the site of the
proposed out building so closer in view
of the existing tennis court and the
trees surrounding photograph taken from
the former tennis court looking back
towards the Old Rectory again taken from
the garden area this is at the front to
the site so this is the church and the
corner of the the Old Rectory there okay
so so outside of the site this is
outside of the site looking in you can
see the the Old Rectory they're the
difficult and the site of the proposed
outbuilding which would be behind the
the trees this is a view is taken from
the public footpath itself with the
applications like to noted there the
arrow should be on the trees and the
views looking south from the death cut
that difficult behind me and this
photograph looking down towards the
river so that's the end of the the
presentation there is one update to
report chair and that's the addition of
Kinison parish plan which was adopted
since the agenda was prepared chairman
the recommendation is to refuse the
application for the recess reasons
stated on pages 70 and 71 of the agenda
paper from Kosovars
okay can we do this can we do this at
the em off Wellstone enough okay path
runs no problem
great so we have the applicant and agent
I believe or at the applicant Richard
part good evening that's what could I
just ask who everyone is at the table
because okay thank you very much so
you'll have three minutes turn your
microphone on and I'll give you a half
minute yes I'm sure
perfect well thank you for allowing me
to address the committee I'd like to
think that the scheme speaks for itself
and self-explanatory so I just like to
reinforce two issues the setting and the
planning policy and the issue of special
circumstances we carried out a pre app
and I quote the officer's comments given
the existing tennis court piecemeal shet
arrangement and lower level of the site
the provision of a new Orangery and wall
garden could be seen as appropriate
provided that the scale and design is no
longer la larger or grander than the
sketch scheme we responded to this in a
reduction in scale and a removal some
branda detailing namely a window to the
rear of the proposal I hope the
committee will accept Jo Manning's
endorsement of the desert design when
considering if special circumstances
apply it's important to see the proposal
as part of a collection of buildings all
sitting appropriately and in harmony
with each other the wall garden sits
down and subservient to the rectory so
on the left hand photograph it's what
it's the top of that proposal is just
slightly higher than the terrace the
satellite view on the next page I shows
how the site has been tidied up and
cleansed there are outbuildings to the
yeah exactly there which will be removed
and the dotted line indicates the
proposal where the proposal sits within
the existing tennis court arrangement
which will be removed so the removal of
the unsightly outbuildings which are
visible across the fields reduces the
spread of development and compact the
buildings into an area with no visible
harm to the wider landscape or the
setting of the buildings there is no
infringement upon the openness of the
Greenbelt I welcome the approach of the
parish council and the summary of the
councillor Gettis we can live inside
this I just wanted to demonstrate where
that where it sits and behind I think
we've Charles already covered this but
it actually sits well with that behind
this tree line and is not visible from
the wider landscape
I appreciate the planning policy and the
respect required for the Greenbelt
however here is a unique opportunity to
enclose the site and down the site with
a high grade piece of architecture and
landscape design the next slide the
historical map demonstrates a special
circumstance restore the presence of
outbuildings on this corner of the site
next slide the details taken from other
buildings on the side and there are
copious outbuildings are to be applied
onto the new scheme our images here in
the next slide point historic precedents
form and at our reference point to
recreate this special garden finally an
aerial view to show what the result
could be if we accept that a solution of
this caliber of architectural design in
is a positive enough addition to justify
special circumstance and a net gain and
win on this site albeit in the Greenbelt
I believe it is I was thanking the
officers for their advice and help I
have to emphasize that as demonstrated
in these images this scheme has no
impact at all on the openness and visual
immunity of the Greenbelt
lovely thank you very much
any questions councillor bombs
yes great great - yes any other
questions can Sir Richard can you tell
me a bit about the materials that you're
planning to use and also can you give me
a rough idea of the size in terms of
volume and floor space compared to the
house I could answer the second question
I can't give you this I haven't actually
got to follow those numbers to hand so I
don't know the size of the house it is
the reason we carried out a pre app and
and I had a site visit and many
conversations with Jo Manning was
actually to ensure that this was
respectful of the setting and because of
the the level changes in the site it
actually sits way below all of those
other buildings so so what was the first
question materials in my slide when I
showed details of the other outbuildings
there's a very clear hierarchy on this
site with the greatest addres tree
having quite fine painted plaster
details around the windows 18th century
brick their proposal is to actually
build the the wall garden and Orangery
out of exactly the same scale brick so
it would be it would it would match and
blend in with the existing site and it
would also take the as its starting
point details from the current out
building some of them which are actually
dilapidated include farm which were all
part of this settlement those details
which is secondary and and further down
the hierarchy of buildings on this side
would be used on the walls and put and
the Orangery so just on clay is it
reclaimed brick that you're going to use
or is it new brick that just looks a
little bit like that I will it would be
handmade brick which which would
actually look exactly like the old brick
thanks Clara Barnes
what is the height of the new proposed
building compared with the building
because you said you were lower so just
to clarify the buildings which have been
taken down because the proposal is is
for clearing that air of the site the
moment that I was the tennis court and
there are other outbuildings and a
greenhouse to spread across there is an
old shed this quite about 50 years old
and then there's a greenhouse there are
a collection of sheds and greenhouses
which actually spread down through the
garden those would be taken away and the
greenhouse would then be within the wall
around this area of the garden so you
wouldn't see it from the wider
countryside okay I have any other
questions good I did have a question
it's gone never mind
okay thank you very much well she does
go as far as to say the proposals are
considered acceptable thank you we've
noted that thank you can you turn the
button off as well please any technical
questions Richards size wise so
comparing this in terms of its floor
space and volume to the house could you
give me a rough idea I can try the best
thing I can probably do is to okay so
that's the size of this outbuilding it
would in terms of floor space it would
take up pretty much most of that or just
just just a bit less than most of that
right
angular parcel of land their floor space
floor space wise it's it would appear on
that basis to be bigger than the house
but volume-wise the house is obviously
three floors and this is over one yes
that's right it is a single storey
building and the if they are quoted in
the report that it's a it's just under
two thousand cubic meters not I get it
about 1800 so could it be considered
subserve in your mind but it considered
subservient to the main dwelling given
that scale inside sorry would you
consider it to be subservient to the
mainland building based on that size no
I wouldn't know not based on that on
that side okay you're quite welcome to
stay there or order move back but no but
I'm sorry we can't hear any more we've
had we've had that so there's no comment
further any other any other questions
well counselor pastor do you want to ask
a question now Kent sir
Giles obviously we heard in the
presentation from the applicant that in
his opinion there's no infringement on
the openness of the Greenbelt I've got
two questions and I just wanted what
your view about was yeah I mean I think
I think a building of this size and
scale my professional view is it would
be it would be difficult not to impact
on the openness of the Greenbelt we have
a situation where we have a disused
tennis court here which obviously has a
hard standing and a bit of fencing
around it that really doesn't compare to
what is being proposed here in terms of
the scale and size and in my view this
will impact the openness degree about
quite significantly just just to pick up
on the point about openness openness in
the Greenbelt is an absolute thing it
applies whether or not there's any
screening floor it if it's there it's
affecting the openness if it has any
volume it affects the open that in some
way so it doesn't matter if the
screening in terms of the Greenbelt test
the landscape test one more from Carol
Giles and my second question was in
terms of its size and given the length
really the length of that plot that it
takes up how does it compare with the
church because I'm getting them from I'm
getting the impression that actually
it's going to be almost as long as the
church there it's good
I just wondering in terms of the
relationship between that building and
the church how they what your view is
about how they interact yeah I mean it's
it's I think floorplan wise it's
comparable it is reasonably distant from
the church so my view would be that it
probably wouldn't I mean it wouldn't
impact the setting of that and obviously
our conservation team would have picked
up on that if they felt that it would ok
can we move to counterbalance that's the
the consolation team supportive of this
proposal in terms of the trees there the
trees are there they are there no the
tree the trees are already in existence
ok I have one on can we get back back
you know the height a lot have been said
about the levels here that that actually
it's only going to poke up a little bit
above the landing or the whatever it is
can you comment on that I can give you a
height the maximum height on this which
is 5 meters to the top of the lantern 5
meters so it's 5 meters to the top of
the lantern which is that the open bit
of the top
I take it but because it's set down in
the tennis court how high will that
fight how high would it go above the the
pavement outside the house so we can't
hear from the back I think this is
probably the best photo really it would
sit the land levels to drop so it would
sit in in that sort of counteract gerson
bear actually do the horizontal which
you said which I presume is the building
height again yes across so from what you
have just illustrated those trees will
shield the new structure there for the
impact on the openness of the Greenbelt
seems to be you know not an issue there
doesn't appear to be a problem there as
far as I can see but in these situations
particularly with a listed building of
this quality and category in my
experience it has always been the
preservation of the setting of the
listed building which has prevented is a
question here it is therefore I cannot
sort of believe that there is any
problem to the openness of the Greenbelt
listed building so what's the question
can question is we're having structures
taken away we're having an eyesore
removed which maybe still sounds like an
argument councillor Siqueiros features I
believe override any perceived tenant s
will not intubate
just a moment I'm asking the question
okay do those features on one not
override any perceived sensitivity about
the openness of the green belt
just to clarify there's three tests the
first test is around the heritage assets
you've got support from the conservation
officer that's why there's no
recommended reason for refusal around
heritage assets the second test is
around the green belt and that's around
its openness and as I said before that's
an absolute test that applies whether
it's screened or not if it has volume it
impacts on the openness and the green
belt test applies and it needs to be
limited in filling otherwise you would
need to find very special circumstances
and finally the third test is around the
impact on the landscape and that is a
test that you can take into account
existing screening although I would
point out that doesn't apply all the way
around because it would be more apparent
in winter so forgive me Carol it was a
very good question
any other questions okay great thank you
so to date and councillor Baum's trees
are in the right place like development
in the green belt but okay anyways
pencil Giles okay I have absolutely no
doubt that the design quality will be
impeccable the proposal for the walled
garden is an extremely sensitive one to
the house in its history and I do also
take into account a little bit surprised
but I take into account the fact the
conservation officer actively supports
it it's not just doesn't object but from
a listed buildings point of view there
isn't that concern however I am minded
to
go with the officers recommendation on
the basis that because I feel the
reasons are very well articulated and
the two issues are open to the Greenbelt
an impact on landscape actually my
significant concern is the is the latter
and I think the paragraph on page 68
which talks about the heritage and
landscape are the reasoning behind the
SLA designation and in this instance I
consider the introduction of a building
of such scale would visually detract
from the virtually undeveloped high
quality art and landscape of this corner
of Canton so in my view from from what I
can see is that this is an almost unique
part of the district in terms of these
collection of buildings and their
character and the way that it interacts
with the landscape the difficult
obviously the National Trust owned
property there is something very special
about the undeveloped nature of that
landscape and I think we have to be
incredibly mindful when we put anything
on it let alone something of this scale
so the scale of this building I think
contributes to the issue of impact on
landscape but clearly it does impact on
the openness of Greenbelt and clearly
putting a building of of this volume no
not withstanding I don't doubt for one
minute the the sensitivity in the way
that it would be built but but of this
scale which is going to have an impact
on the openness of this of the Greenbelt
in an area where it is particularly
important so the issue for me for me is
a scale a nine I understand what counts
our concern is bound to Lutie which is
the issue of trees and whilst they are
an issue we have to consider this site
in the context of it being hundreds of
years old and obviously trees have a
certain shelf life they're not not
always there and they're not always
there all year round so we have to
consider the effects of build built form
which has much more permanent effect and
so I feel quite persuaded by with what I
think is a very well thought about
report in terms of how it weighs up
those things and finally I think there
can't be any dispute that there's an
impact on the openness so we then have
to look for very special circumstances
and I have to say even if one will mind
you to say well actually we quite like
this I quite like it I don't have a
problem you know in all fairness we have
to say are there very special
circumstances and I think frankly one
would really have to grovel to find
those so I would propose a refusal if I
can find a seconder for that Thank You
councillor council of ordering become a
surprise upon Sir Giles but I'd actually
second that I think this does fail the
second test I was laid out by the
Planning Manager has some concern about
scale there is to contrast that we are
tidying up a messy site but that's not
enough for the Greenbelt this wasn't in
a green belt I suspect my position won't
be different it is in the green belt we
can't avoid that discussion so I'm happy
to second proposal from councillor Giles
are there any other comments I would
like to make some comments because
having read the report which I do agree
is very good and it's a very balanced
question I feel that yes it's definitely
a Greenbelt issue so we would definitely
need two five area special circumstances
but I think we have here an incredibly
well thought out plan which has been
consulted with our our heritage expert
our conservation expert and actually
been approved which is which is a rare
day this application has really tried
hard to do something special and
appropriate in this location and I think
that in itself and the resulting design
and the historical precedence we seem to
have for it and the suitability for such
a building in such a location is a very
special circumstance for the Greenbelt I
think the conservation argument has been
made as a positive anyway and the
landscape argument if there was any
effect and it's very heavily screened
very heavily screen
more visual footpaths and things I think
it would be a benefit to the landscape
by introducing this very special and
wonderful design building to that
location so that would so I will be
voting against your your proposal we
have one more comment from the
councillor Barnes no we have a proposal
no more comments so we shall go to the
vote the proposal is to refuse this
application all those in favor of
refusing all those against refusing the
application please raise your hands
so that proposal fails do we have a
another proposal coastal bombs soon with
the conditions that the conservation
architect report seen I don't think I
can make any extra conditions other than
what have been put in okay so we had a
proposal sorry we've got a proposal
we'll need clarification on the reasons
yes that's what we're going to now in my
previous argument I I suggested that the
reasons against the very special sort of
thought the very special circumstances
we need would be the design quality the
from our conservation team and the well
that would be it actually I'd also ask
that you put in the conditions that have
been asked for by our conservation team
so I mean what are your thoughts on
those reasons
I'm quite happy to go along with what
you said I was just initially I was the
purse speaker enough I was definitely
against it reading the paperwork okay I
have moved to the situation where I'm
quite happy just propose okay so we have
a proposal then I think council Atkinson
wanted to say something
can can we have a comment on that if you
talk about Perpetual that would be very
difficult to enforce in the long term
what my comment would be the chances are
it will be maintained but I don't think
we can give any guarantees that it would
bill that we could enforce it into the
long term because if those trees get
diseased or whatever it may be they need
replacing and gaps would open up so so
can can we do anything with them with
the trees or not compute you want to put
a tree protection we're talking about
the protection I think the best you can
do in terms in terms of soft landscaping
is to put a standard soft landscaping
condition on with a five-year
replacement element to it can Sir Giles
okay sorry I must have been you which is
definitely me so I just want absolute
clarity that we as a committee we as a
council from a legal point of view are
satisfied that our very special
circumstances we're going against the
National Greenbelt policy is cuz it's
quite pretty and also I thought to
whether or not one consul tea coming
back saying yes they think it's okay is
a reasonable reason to go against again
a Greenbelt policy it's like saying
waterway said it's alright so let's go
I've put more credibility to or mom
sorry more weight to the officers report
in this instance so I know the officers
report that landscape ops okay I do but
I don't I just don't feel it
they're either reasons you've put
forward can truly and honestly be
considered very special circumstances
given the significant way of Greenbelt
policy okay thank you can see Charles I
know there's a proposal on the table
already and I appreciate that by
wondering whether one option is
considering we are looking at a site of
very significant importance and we are
looking at going against officers
recommendation I'm wondering whether a
site visit is appropriate because I
think that it seems to me as they're
committing it some ways this is quite
split I think there is clearly a very
sensitive site and I'm I'm wondering
where the committee will be better
informed one way or the other
actually in terms of when they see it
see it measured out in in in plan to get
a much better idea of actually what the
impacts will be one way or the other
because okay so hang on everybody
one second already hang on yeah we have
a proposal in a second the very special
circumstances that have been put forward
at a high design quality of the proposal
that's for members I don't have a legal
concern with that if members think the
design is such a high quality it would
have to strongly outweigh in members
Minds the harm to the Greenbelt
you have to deal with the proposal
that's on the table first okay fine so
we have an answer to that we're gonna if
if members want a side visit okay they
can vote against the next proposal that
might work but we we have a proposal and
a second which I'm very happy to go with
the proposal is to grant permission with
the reasons given and the can I suggest
chairman in terms that the conditions
the full extent of the conditions are
delegated to officers in consultation
with yes absolutely
okay so all those in favor of granting
this application please raise your hands
all those against so we have another
proposal for a site visit any second
councillor Richards okay Cara which is
all those in favor of a site visit it's
unanimous
okay right I'm sorry we didn't make any
decision but it will lead to a better
decision when we do make one okay we're
finished with well
we haven't gotten the urgent business so
we will try and organize a date for this
site visit now please throw some
suggestions that Caroline know is still
online I mean should we close okay we're
close the meeting